right to the guys people adds back one
of grab seats yeah okay thank you thank
you to PI data for inviting me here it's
good to see a nice big crowd I'm gonna
talk about popping your filter or pop
your filter bubble a little bit about me
first I have over my career primarily a
systems background okay so that means
that whenever I look at something and
look at it from end-to-end perspective
and that kind of has helped me with
machine learning and it hasn't because
primarily machine learning is not an
end-to-end system okay and I know that
for a fact that nowadays people are kind
of struggling with that whole idea of
actually incorporating machine learning
systems about machine learning into
enterprise systems okay and it's not an
easy task
so I've been at it for 10 years plus
primarily with Zubin gaura vani which I
assume most people know who he is
yes how many don't okay you can look him
up he's one of he's one of the top
machining machine learning guys in the
world focused primarily on Bayesian and
my street cred is that I've been using
Python numpy and scipy since 2007 in
anger I've seen a lot done a lot one of
the highlights that I well one of the
highlights for me was to actually put
thingy which is the product
across a HPC cluster over 1,000 in 24
CPUs
this was that at the Cambridge run in
fact was the old one they've got they've
updated since and if I have time I think
I've only got 25 minutes okay and at
first when they told me I was on I
thought I haven't got enough material
for 25 minutes and now I've got more
than enough material for 25 so I have to
ever cut off but the slides will be
available and I've got results for the
some tests that I did on the HPC okay if
I don't get to it in the presentation
and just to brag a little I've got a
stack overflow reputation somewhere so
we're going to either bubble first and
this is really kind of a few were Dees
lights but kind of hang in there I'm not
going to hang around too long talking
about it but it's important that I do
because it provides context and I'm sure
it's a reason why a lot of you are here
then we'll talk about the concept of the
filter which is you know recommendation
engines and what makes thingy different
and then pop which is really looking at
thing itself and what I'm going to be
doing is I'm going to show you example
results okay of what makes it different
all right
and these are real examples okay so
bubble so I don't think there's any
doubt right that the 2016 brick said
referendum and the u.s. election were a
turning point okay and if you read the
media you know you know it does matter
which side of the argument you're on it
was still a turning point we know that
bad stuff happened right and it
continues to happen globally and more
and more social media and recomendation
engines are being implicated
and suddenly in the u.s. the worm has
turned the worm meaning technology
journalists right who have always been
to be honest in the pockets of
technology companies okay they will
always do the they will always follow
what the technology vendors are doing
they'll report them in good in a good
way but what we've seen in the last few
months is that it's slowly turning
around they turn these journalists
actually turning on the vendors
themselves and I'm going to quote Kara
Swisher who is probably one of the most
influential journalists in technology in
the United States and has recently
started writing for the New York Times
and so just two weeks ago she wrote that
I'll just quote what she said that
Facebook have weaponized social media
and we are all paying the price I don't
think anyone's going to disagree with
that and that Facebook Twitter and
YouTube have become the digital arms
dealers of the modern age they have
mutated from connecting people to
pitting them against one another and
turbocharged that discord to an
unprecedented and damaging volume but
the bit that I want to emphasize is the
last one there's no solution in sight
because they were built to work exactly
this way okay and in fact if you I
recommend that you find this and I have
a read of it and actually she says they
really don't have a solution to this
they built a technology and it works in
a certain way and it's gone to an
extreme level and for them to try and
they can scale somewhere back they still
going to work in the same way Francois
shall not Chalet I don't have to say
that right is the author inventor of
Paris which is part of tensorflow now
okay and he also wrote this wonderful
essay in March
which I would also recommend that you go
and have a read of and he said his super
intelligence the real danger which is
what most people are panicking about
nowadays right or the scalable
manipulation of human behavioral
behavior AR enables and it's malicious
use and it's also entered into popular
culture okay how many people have seen
Incredibles - I'm not giving any
spoilers how many is that it okay so
you've got it so you haven't got kids
all right okay the villain is called
screen Slayer okay and you can see him
at the top there with the bright eyes
okay and the screen Slayer basically
takes over people's mind an agency does
it remind you of anyone now the
interesting thing is right actually
Incredibles 2 is the highest grossing
domestic highest grossing animation
movie in the u.s. so far and probably
will be worldwide okay so that's another
reason to go and see the interesting
thing is right if you look at villains
right in superhero movies or animation
movies right you know it's the mall or
you know what was the one in Incredibles
or one what was that
syndrome yeah syndrome you know okay and
you know they were just kind of
characters you knew were not real yeah
but yet this is the first time you've
got a villain that you know about okay
because you use it every day okay let's
move on to the filter
so recommendations engines have spreads
like a virus because of open source look
that might sound controversial but it's
not okay you know I've been using open
source software for a long time open
source libraries right and if I were to
do something I'm going look on github
try and find a library or pipe I and
most likely all I'll do right it's just
thick data into it I won't mess around
with the actual core algorithm and off I
go and I think that's how most people
use libraries don't they like you don't
actually go digging around in the core
algorithm to try and change it you just
want something that would work you look
at the easiest way to do that I think
and it's because of that ease of use
right that recommendation engines have
just literally just spread right
everyone uses them and they all use the
same one and recommendation engines or
behave the same where each customer or
consumer is put into a single lane okay
without any control okay really
important the consumer has no control to
look at whether it's a Facebook News
Feed or you know other ones even Netflix
right it just gives it to you and you
can't do anything about it right so it's
a closed Road right it's not like the
open road where you're given control of
the car okay so that was about control
this is other quotes from a very popular
newsletter called
inside AI and the guy Rob made was the
author of the newsletter and also the
CEO of a AI company and investor in AI
companies he said this was just a couple
of weeks ago if companies don't start
embracing AI they're going to be left
behind
why AI requires
multiple areas of change now requires
training of the software more than
training of the user okay well we know
about that this is a new concept that
requires a new work a new that requires
new workflows but users aren't
accustomed to and there and then he says
every AI software CEO I know
complain software buyers treat this like
a normal software sale it isn't it's
much more existential than that right
and I've actually I said that I work for
instance I have a systems background but
I've actually worked for us software
companies to involved with systems right
and I know this is just hogwash ok
because it's just self-serving now
you've got AI software CEOs saying to
companies to enterprises to
organizations sorry if you want AI
you're gonna have to change your
enterprise workflows the ones that you
spend decades building in order to
support AI which is static on one hand
you've got dynamic workflows and then
you've got the AI CEOs and their sales
people saying yeah his AI it's static
now you change your workflows to fit
around this I laugh
okay and that's my message you know
enterprises and organizations have to be
really careful okay and you couldn't
understand that this difference between
dynamic and AI which is primarily static
systems if we go back in the past of
work computing
let's look at two examples of dynamic or
real-time algorithms the B tree and B+
tree is now in every single database
management system in the world cuz Melo
who brings one out who's got one there's
a B tree data structure behind it okay
it was invented at Boeing in the
seventies for document management and
you can understand why Boeing wanted to
do that right and they got this huge
massive plane and you've got a ton of
documents right they needed a way to
actually store all those documents and
that's where the genesis of B trees
started and around the 80s and 90s
Oracle introduced real-time transactions
and if you think about real-time
transactions okay without it the
Internet today or e-commerce would just
not work because you know someone buy
something okay
that has to be recorded and has to be
shown to the buyer or whoever else that
that transaction happened and it's got
to happen immediately okay we expect
immediate response on internet but and
without this B tree right would not have
happened and my point there is that
people actually went out and tried to
solve this problem the other one is the
inverted index which was designed for
information retrieval and the early use
was actually in mainframe databases the
most favored most famous one being a de
bas in the seventies but it was not
until the search engines on the internet
came along that the inverted index
started being used more forcefully and
the and Google real-time indexing was
actually in the early 2000s and again
they modified or built stuff around the
inverted index to support real-time
indexing okay and nowadays you go on
Google and you expect it to have the
latest information all the time learning
algorithms invented by academics
researchers for experimental research in
the between the 50s and 90s all right
and you know even deep learning whatever
if you you know look at the work and
they were and the people behind it will
admit to you that these are old
algorithms what changed was that compute
cheap compute became available as well
as massive amounts of data but the
actual algorithms themselves are not new
they've iterated upon them since but not
much okay so they were not designed for
real world use they're not dynamic
they're not interactive so you have no
control over it and they do not scale in
production it may scale offline when
you're doing you know ETL extract
extracting or transforming and loading
you know when they're using Hadoop or
spark or whatever right but they do not
scale when they're in production
so this is the traditional of the
conventional machine learning pipelines
okay at the far end you've got data you
do feature engineering which you can do
either manually or with deep learning we
then pass those feature vectors into
your machine learning algorithm and you
train test and deploy right and you get
your model and then you make predictions
before unseen data but in the real world
you always get new data okay when that
happens you know depends on the
application for someone like Netflix
which I used I typically see that they
read to retrain the entire system every
two to three days so you've got new data
you still don't feature engineering okay
but you are now retraining retesting and
redeploying and you give you a static
model with your predictions okay and
like I said you know when you retrain
retest redeployed just depends on the
application itself
so what's dynamic machine
what's dynamic machine learning well
what happens if you just take away this
offline component and all the retraining
retesting and redeploy
and also get rid of the static model and
that's what we have what we have is this
production okay check out your data you
could have creature engineering your
feature vectors go straight into the
machine learning algorithm and then you
make predictions based on your unseen
data just to go back I forgot to mention
something here in this model right your
machine you got your feature vectors and
your machine learning algorithm works on
the feature vectors okay to create your
static model okay once you've got your
static model you are deployed but your
feature vectors are left
they offline you don't do anything more
with them yeah in our world
you've got your features and the machine
learning works on the feature vectors
dynamically in real time yeah all right
let's move on to the thingy solution
okay so a thing is a dynamic
recommendation engine has three
components
the first one is automatic
generalization so it makes inferences in
real time you can call it real-time
learning is another word for automatic
generalization the other component is
it's interactive which means that it's
driven by queries into the engine
through an API and you can have and
right now we've got one two three four
different query api's and on the other
side is dynamic right where you can add
feature vectors update them update an
existing feature vector delete them and
also just read them okay you can do this
live a live system
so what's going on great simply we have
a universe of things and those things
could actually be any data type you
would okay there are no restrictions on
the data types with these images videos
documents you can even combine them if
you want as feature vectors you have
your query and your query contains
components and I'll talk a bit more
about that in second right and you get
results back right and the results are
ranked by how well each thing fits into
the universal things so let's look at
one let's look at query all right I know
that I'm primarily about recommendation
engines but I've used images because
it's just visually better to Wow I only
got five minutes left what wow that was
quick I just got started
all right so I've used a wiki art data
set the feature vectors were obtained
through deep learning okay and what we
have at the top is the query image and
then the results okay nothing special
here you can see this in other systems
today yes okay so you can imagine this
like being available in the museum where
it's recommending paintings yeah now I
can add a second image or painting to a
query okay and it will immediately go
away and give me results that are
similar to both of the query images
yep see that not I can add a third image
to the query okay and you can see how
the results change and the results are
also remember it it's almost like
mashing all three of those query images
and then finding stuff that's similar to
that I can add a fourth one and I love
how in the bottom road the middle one
how that one turns up there okay I
didn't remove actually let me just stop
let me just say something here okay so
that query there at the top right with
four okay there's two ways of looking at
this right standard that okay you know
i'm i've got this machine learning
recommendation recommendation engine and
I can put a query that consists of
multiple items there and was go and find
similar stuff to open yeah that's the
standard way the the other way to look
at it is to say that those four
represent personalization so it could
represent you in some way okay and then
you can keep that on your system
somewhere to say yeah this is Fred this
is Joan
whoever okay and every time you use that
set of items which represent a person it
will get personalized recommendations
okay
same thing we start with one image add a
second one I had two more I can take
two away take as many as you want away
right I notice results change each time
the API it's almost kind of standard
Python API nothing too clever going on
right now we've got a query request type
for query query more creep positive
query negative you enter the request
type the number of results you want back
whether you with the scores or not okay
and that makes up the payload okay I
definitely want to do this one hold on
to more okay the next one is a query
with more like this and these okay so
I've got those query images at the top
three I get the result images and then I
say right give me more like that second
one on the top that's right and I get
these again nothing clever you can get
this in other types of systems but what
if we said give me from the result
images give me two give me more like
those two and off it goes and it does
that and if you notice on the second one
on the right right is two people I think
on a bench there okay and the first one
it's found another one with people on a
bench all right yeah this was the one
that I really wanted to show you okay
the next one is more like these lists
like others alright so I've got two
query images and I've got the results
set again it's paintings now what I'm
going to do right is mark up as positive
the top line and the first three
and mark is negative of the other two
okay and I do a query on that and it
gives me these yeah now if I reverse it
I say give me more like the negatives
and less like the positives I get these
all right and so it's like a yin and
yang does make sense yep so in a way
it's kind of saying you know give me the
positive stuff but you know there's a
little bit of you know the dark stuff in
there or give me all the dark stuff but
leave your little light stuff in there
okay again it's all done through the API
now a big one is actually I said on the
dynamic part is actually adding data
right or whether you're updating it okay
but I redone thing I'm going to how much
time ago
yeah okay guys I tell you what this is
gonna be on the slides okay because it's
kind of you know I have to kind of
explain it step by step
right but this is really a key set of
slides right about adding data in real
time well adding feature vectors in real
time okay
and I said the right at beginning that
you know consumers don't have control
right now when they use recommendation
engines okay but now they can all right
and the way you do it is to provide the
relevant uix controls okay so you know
when it's more or less you can have
engineered serendipity we start you
could actually just you know use the
api's in inventive ways and create your
own right now one of the good things is
that you're not leaving the consumers in
the lurch you're giving them like an
open road different ways to go including
restart go back to the beginning if you
have to and a road map is a
recommendation engine for everything
okay some people call this multimodal
learning you know put documents and
video and you know images and you know
try and find the stuff so from the work
that I've done earlier this year I know
I've solved this problem okay and I just
need to just test it out now but I know
it will work and it will work literally
anything okay so you do a query and bang
if you know if you've got mixed media
mixed data types it will find it it will
bring it back and just quickly vision
you can't have a presentation without a
vision right it really is about giving
people control of their a
okay if we don't do this right we're all
going to be in a lot of trouble down the
road
and I think we already are in a lot of
trouble I also hope that we couldn't get
a new generation of dynamic AI services
there's no reason why we can't have a
new Netflix okay or even you know new
social media services if you want just
needs entrepreneurs to recognize what
they can do and I also hope that there's
a greater focus in the future about on
dynamic AI okay you know just like with
the b-tree and the inverted index you
know if there's a need now okay you
can't have static systems being joined
with dynamic systems it just doesn't
make any sense and that's my last like
[Applause]